NFL star and likely hall-of-famer adrian
peterson in debt quote taken advantage
of by those he trusted unquote this
report says adrian peterson is
reportedly in debt a shocking revelation
for a future hall of fame running back
who has made more than one hundred
million dollars during his career
peterson who last played for the vikings
in 2016 is the focus of a report from
the athletic paywall that claims he's
being sued in pennsylvania because he
did not pay back 5.2 million dollars in
loans in addition to two other legal
matters where he's been ordered to pay
creditors that combine three million
dollars the three million dollars owed
to creditors includes six hundred
thousand left on a 2.4 million dollar
loan from a minnesota bank
in a statement to pro football tok tok
Peterson's attorney said the truth
behind Adrian Peterson's current
financial situation is more than is
being reported at this time while adding
it is yet another situation of an
athlete trusting the wrong people and
being taken advantage of by those he
trusted Peterson is entering his second
season with the Washington Redskins is
due to make a million dollars of salary
after receiving a 1.5 million dollar
signing bonus
earlier this year according to / the cat
Peterson's career earnings not including
endorsement money totals 100 million two
hundred twenty one thousand four and
seventy one dollars about five years ago
ESPN's documentary series profile
athletes who go broke despite making
millions the film highlighted a 2009
Sports Illustrated article that claimed
78 percent of former NFL players had
gone bankrupt or were under financial
stress because of bad investments
freeloaders and ongoing medical problems
yet another one of these stories of
famous people athletes and actors and so
forth who made a hundred million dollars
and have nothing it just breaks my heart
it's just sad
long before Adrian Peterson entered the
league Chris Hogan and I were attempting
to work with the NFL and work with the
players to try to keep this from
happening to them because this has been
a stereotype almost among professional
athletes of all types and there's really
only two types of famous people that
become rich there I mean I know a bunch
of them like hundreds of athletes and
you know Hollywood actor types and
certainly music people I'm in Nashville
so I know a ton of those guys and
there's two types there Adrian Peterson
they have no idea what's going on
someone else is managing everything and
they lose it all or they're very savvy
business people and they do a good job
watching over their business and they
actually know what's going on they're
not trying to out-earn someone else's
stupidity they actually have a clue
what's going on and in the NFL when you
walk in the locker room and it's not
based on race and it's not based on
anything that that's really tangible
some of it has to do with upbringing
probably but when we walk into an NFL
locker room we really find two groups
very smart and very stupid and there's
just not a middle ground
there's nobody just kind of hanging out
in the middle sort of doing okay I find
people are very savvy with their
investments they've got their act
together they may or may not agree with
a hundred percent of what I say but
they're really doing well and they're
gonna come out of the leak very wealthy
and the rest of them it doesn't matter
what they make they're gonna lose it you
can tell they are an accident looking
for a freaking place to happen I know
that happens when I meet with young
music stars because their careers and
their income oftentimes grows faster
than their emotional maturity and
certainly faster than their financial
understanding
things and so they turn it over to a
manager and I used the term lightly and
almost every case you end up with
nothing and you know I remember we've
got permission to tell this we don't I'm
not mentioning any names of these other
people that I've met with because I
don't have their permission but we've
met with hundreds and hundreds of them
and an NFL player in here gosh it wasn't
within the last year or so he and his
wife came and sat down and was not a
recognizable household name but you know
he's a he played on Sunday he didn't
ride the bench and he came in hollered
at Chris Chris knew him from somewhere
and sat in my conference room for just a
few minutes I had just a minute between
a meeting and he he said I'm David I'm
just kind of ashamed to tell you where I
am and I'm like where are you what you
do how can we help and what happened and
I'm figure he's getting ready tell me
that you know all that stupid butt stuff
he's done like this Adrian Peterson
article and he says I've got thirty two
million dollars and I said okay and
what's wrong with this he said it's all
sitting in CDs in the bank and I went
okay but you got thirty two million
dollars so I don't think there's
anything to hang your head in the shame
about you did more than almost anybody
in the league does now let's we'll work
with you and help you get it invested
and you know get you with an investment
adviser and you need to start
understanding basic investments that you
stay on top of but you don't hang your
head for having thirty two million
dollars in the CDs because he just knew
he should be doing something else with
it that was the only point so here's the
thing the lesson for all of us is to
fold in these Adrian Peterson stories
number one Adrian's not a bad guy I
don't know him personally but he hadn't
done anything that everybody said and
done - he just thought he could play
football and somebody would take care of
him and you know all of us think the
Lone Ranger is coming that the Calvary
is coming all of us think that someone's
going to come along and take care of us
and that's lesson number one part of
being a grown-up whether you play
football or play guitar or whether it's
you part of being a grown-up is knowing
and realizing and acting on the fact
that your money and your future is your
responsibility you cannot turn this over
to someone else and walk away and expect
anything but disaster that's how people
put putting money and stuff like Bernie
Madoff that's how people put money in
ridiculous business ideas that's how
they turned the money loose and they
walk away and say I've got a guy that
takes care of me no you don't you've got
a guy that's a doofus and he's gonna
lose your money the second rule is not
only is it your job to handle your own
money and make sure you know where it's
going even with the advice of others but
the second rule is you can outturn your
stupidity we all have the ability to be
stupid beyond our income no matter what
our income is you can't make enough to
be stupid you can't make that much money
the stupid tax is too high
so I'm sad for Adrienne this is awful